das bin ich und ich werde die nächsten
100 Tage mit meiner Virtual Reality
Brille in Minecraft verbringen frag mich
nicht wie ich auf die Idee gekommen
bin och nee diger wieso spaw ich denn
jedes Mal auf einer Insel aber gut
Freunde machen wir das Beste raus und
bauen erstmal ein bisschen Holz
ab auch ziemlich logisch dass man das in
Minecraft einfach mit seiner bloßen Hand
machen kann Kri richtig Nackenschmerzen
ne fün Holz haben wir am Start von
da oh mein Gott Alter ich glaube ich
habe mich noch nie so vor Baum
erschrocken wir schnappen uns auf jeden
Fall erstmal ein paar eichenholzbretter
und warum ist es plötzlich so
hell ah guten Morgen wir machen uns
erstmal eine Werkbank so die Werkbank
wählen wir jetzt aus und platzieren die
hier ach guck mal da vorne ist zumindest
ist direkt Festland boah das sieht geil
aus
ne also ich meine es
ist war mal wie funktioniert überhaupt
schwimmen nein sag jetzt nicht
ne
ne ich muss wirklich schwimmen damit ich
von A nach B komme ich würde allerdings
sagen wir holen uns erstmal noch ein
bisschen mehr
Holz
direkt nach wieder ins Gym gehen Alter
und jetzt machen wir uns erstmal die
wichtigsten was
[Musik]
das es ist wundervoll hier ich mag
schauen wir mal was wird aber gut Leute
wir graben uns erstmal ein Ticken runter
gönnen uns den ersten Stein den es hier
irgendwie gibt und machen uns jetzt
erstmal steinsachen die
wir
nein nee das ist nicht
wahr ich muss jetzt ach du heilige
Scheiße ich muss jetzt in echt springen
damit ich hier
[Musik]
hochkme es ist echt ein Workout guck mal
wer da ist wenigstens ist er noch da ich
habe mir dann auf jeden Fall erstmal ein
paar Werkzeuge gecraftet noch ein paar
Steine abgebaut und ein paar Bäume
gefällt wovor ich hier in Virtual
Reality halt V real am meisten Angst
habe ist die Nacht wenn irgendwelche
Zombies kommen monst nein das ist jetzt
nicht wahr
oder ich würde sagen dass wir vorerst
auf dieser kleinen Insel hier bleiben
bevor wir jetzt irgendwie da hinten
rüber gehen auf Festland oder ich glaube
in die Richtung hat ich auch irgendwie
was gesehen einfach weil ich V real
bisher noch ziemlich großen Respekt habe
was Monster so Angt ich weiß noch nicht
genau wie man kämpft wie das klappen
soll in Virtual Reality
dicker das mit dem H mich echt
hops ach du scheiße das ist der Mond
ne okay wir brauchen ganz ganz schnell
fauckeln wie sprin ich eigentlich wir ma
uns jetzt erst mal einen Ofen und im
Ofen können wir jetzt
Eichenstämme hier unten reinpacken Zack
und oben
Bretter andersrum dadurch dass der Ofen
jetzt quasi Holz mit Holz verbrennt
Minecraft gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn
dadurch bekommen wir allerdings auf
jeden Fall gleich Holzkohle und können
mit dieser Holzkohle Fackeln machen s
dass hier auf dieser kleinen Insel wir
zumindest erstmal alles ausleuchten
können das im besten Fal
[Musik]
hier das hört sich gar nicht gut an ich
habe mir dann auf jeden Fall noch ein
paar Fackeln gecraftet meine Insel ein
bisschen ausgeleuchtet und dann leider
plötzlich einen alten Bekannten wieder
getroffen chillig fange ich einmal so
eine Virtual Reality scheiße an direkt
kommt dieser
gabelhacker oh mein Gott der kann Land
ich dachte kann nur Wasser bleiben was S
ich
machen
direkt Bruder oh mein Gott es macht mir
jetzt schon keinen Spaß mehr ich habe
mich dem gabelhacker dann in einem
ferenkampf
gestellt und dann ging auch schon die
Sonne auf wir haben die erste Nacht in
Minecraft vir reality lebt und damit
auch Tag 1 geschafft fehlen nur noch 99
ich habe den Morgen des zweiten Tages
dann dafür genutzt ein paar Bäume zu
fällen und dementsprechend Holz zu
farmen 42 Holzstämme haben wir am Start
undon daher werde ich das jetzt erstmal
zu eichenholzbrettern weiter verarbeiten
und diese dann nehmen um mir ein Boot zu
craften wie geht das noch mal ach moin
Mr
Schildkröte mit dem
eichenholzboot werden wir
jetzt
ach diger ist das
lachkick funktioniert das
jetzt oh mein Gott mir wird so
schwindelig oh mein Gott mir wird
richtig schwindelig
gerade ich w krank ihr fragt euch
wahrscheinlich Luca warum bist du denn
jetzt hier vorne Festland
gelaufen das hat ganz einfachen Grund
denn um Nächte zu überspringen in
Minecraft msen natürlich ein Bett
haben und für ein Bett brauchen wir
Wolle und für
[Musik]
wolle das war mein
Mikro
ob wir irgendwo ein Schaf
sehen
oh oh oh das ist ein
Dschungel
moin
oh zwei ich braue jeden Fall eine Schere
okay das heißt wir müssen doch da vorne
hin das sollten wir hinkriegen
oder Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle
Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle Kohle
bevor ich jetzt wieder auf meine kleine
Insel rüber fahren muss dachte ich mir
nutze ich mal eben die Gunst der Stunde
und crafte mir auf diesem Festland hier
eben einen Ofen wo wir dann fix unsere
Eisen Braten werden sod dass wir im
besten Falle dann mit der Schere von
zwei Schafen drei Wolle bekommen dann
hätten wir ein Bett und könnten die
Nacht
überspringen und
jetzt zwei zwei perfekt wir brauchen nur
noch das andere Schaf jetzt Mo Leute
Trix
hier
wo ist denn das
Schaf h war do V ein
zweites das kann do nicht wahr
sein da ist es bitte bitte bitte bitte
bitte auch zwei perfekt wir können uns
ein B craften okay oh da ist das andere
Schaf nur bitte keine Monster bitte
keine Monster ich sehe da vorne ist das
Huhn okay wir können uns unsere weiße
Wolle nehmen zack wir nehmen unsere
eichenholzbretter zack Kön uns ein Bett
nehmen das Bett auswählen hier
hinsetzen ja ich hab geschat
H Mo Leute hier doch nicht
scheiße
Leute und Leute
hier und Leute ich kann nicht
spren
leuteellell schnell weg schnell weg W
ister da schnell weg diger mir wird
schlecht
ne boah ich muss mich irgendwie
da
ja hat do Spaß
gemacht